Guten Morgen Tim.
Guten Morgen Linus, willst mir jetzt die Show stehlen oder was? Ja. Na toll, immerhin ist es heute Morgen halbwegs.
Guten Morgen.
Ja, na ja, auf jeden Fall sind wir frisch. Also ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall noch ausreichend frisch.
Ja, ich habe hier gerade ja eine Mate ähm bekommen, die.
Oh, das wäre jetzt auch genau das Richtige für mich. Na ja, man kann nicht alles haben.
Man kann nicht alles haben.
Über Koffeinierung ist vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer angemessen. Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall äh feiern wir hier das äh siebenunddreißigste Bestehen äh des Vorkommens einer Logbuch Netzpolitiksendung,
ist ein bisschen unrunder Geburtstag, aber man muss ja die Feste feiern, wie sie fallen,
Und äh ja, ich frage mich natürlich, äh womit äh steigen wir äh womit steigen wir denn jetzt ein hier in diese tolle.
Sendung, ja vielleicht kurz mit den äh mit den Kommentaren zum zum letzten, zur letzten Sendung. Und zwar gab's dann ähm
zum Thema Netzwerkität meldeten sich einige äh sehr aufmerksame Beobachter, die mich dann zum Beispiel darauf hinwiesen, dass es schon seit Jahren äh bei E Plus Usus ist, dass man äh auch ohne Datentarif auf ähm,
auf die Facebookseite gratis zugreifen kann.
Also selbst wenn überhaupt gar keinen Datentarif.
Keinen hat, ja.
Ähm also nur auf Facebook und irgendwie auch nur über eine bestimmte Domain. Null Punkt Facebook dot com. Ähm.
Zero sozusagen.
Zero Facebook. Ja und dann kannst kommst du für ähm auf Facebook. Ähm,
Das ist net, also das wäre ja quasi so eines dieser großen Schreckenszenarien, die der Grund, warum das, glaube ich, da wurde ich gefragt, war das nicht schon der Dammbruch? Ja, in gewisser Form natürlich schon so ein bisschen. Ähm
meine Argumentation wäre, dass äh,
Ich glaube, wenn du, wenn man gar keinen Datentari hat bei Facebook und dann von diesem Facebook Dot com woanders hinklickt, dann kommen die Daten trotzdem und man muss dann halt Kilo äh kilobitweise bezahlen.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Kilo oder wie die abrechnen, würde ich jetzt von ausgehen,
und ist halt so ein Anfix-Angebot. Ähm aber ja, ist ganz klar und ist äh ist auch auch das ist äh nicht gut und äh sondern eher das das Gegenteil, ja. Also so ein so ein ähm.
Also mir war das auch neu. Aber na ja, also solche äh Diesel gemacht und bisher gibt's da so richtig kein Mittel dagegen.
Genau und dann gab es eine Veranstaltung in vor ein paar Tagen wo war sie denn?
Ähm,
Der Link ist falsch. Also gab's eine Veranstaltung, wo man sich mit ähm der Netzneutralität auseinandergesetzt hat und ähm
im Jahr den Jahreskongress der Deutschen
Breitbandinitiative. Und da waren natürlich dann alle die äh Breitband äh Hardware bauen und Breitbanddienste anbieten zusammen. Und da wurde ein äh wurde dann natürlich über diese Netznetralität gesprochen.
Breitbandinitiative.
Ja, Breitbandsinitiatives und Verband.
Aha, noch nie gehört.
Ja ähm war jetzt auch nicht so enorm bekannt, aber äh ich
Auch eher so Breko und solche Dinger. Die deutsche Breitbandinitiative ist ein gemeinsames Projekt A der Initiative D einundzwanzig des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums und des Bitcom. Okay, dann wird ein Schuh draus.
So klang das auch grade, als ob's sowas sein könnte. Mhm.
So und da äh wandert die dann natürlich alle äh beisammen und da sagte dann, äh richtig mal der Walter Haas von Huawei Deutschland. Huawei ist dieser chinesische Anbieter von ähm,
Netzwerk, Hardware, und solchen solchen Scherzen.
Huawei sagt man dann wahrscheinlich doch meistens, auch wenn das vielleicht die richtige Aussprache gewesen sein mag, die du dir so heißt das ja. Oh, wow.
Wie man das ausspricht. Huawei, aber Huawei, ja, also Huawei, Huawei, Deutschland ist, heißt die Firma und äh der sagte dann
Video an demand ist ja eigentlich ein Horror fürs Netz. Ja, stimmt.
Also äh zumindest, wenn man, wenn jeder irgendwie den Staat und den Endpunkt seines Videos und den Pausepunkt selber bestimmen kann, ist das äh absolut richtig
und ähm
Er sagt, dass äh er oder eigentlich waren sich da alle einig, dass sie, wenn es so weitergehen sollte, dass alle jetzt irgendwie da ihren Schrott ins Internet reinpumpen, wir uns über andere Bezahlmodelle ähm Gedanken machen müssen,
Ähm und äh das ist sogar etwas, was äh in dem Fall sogar stimmt, weil durch diese Flatrates, die ja den Leuten irgendwie geboten werden, die Provider tatsächlich,
Sie haben vermutlich ihre Flatrate-Preise irgendwann mal zu einer Zeit berechnet, als sie noch nicht ganz klar war, welche Entwicklung diese Videogeschichte im Internet nehmen würde, weil sie können sich ihre äh Flatrates im zunehmenden Maße wohl,
so nicht mehr leisten beziehungsweise den Datenhunger, den ihre Kunden zeigen.
Ja, dann müssen sie halt ihre Preise erhöhen.
Müssen sie halt die Preise erhöhen oder äh,
oder hätten halt von vorneherein mal weniger Gewinn ausschütten sollen und irgendwie in die in das Netz investieren. Ähm aber wir wollen das jetzt nicht im so in aller in aller Breite diskutieren, was nur
ich suche gerade diese schöne Zitat. Ähm da geht's dann das ist, glaube ich, immer die Telekom, die so etwas sagt.
Ähm nee, das ist jetzt der Alf Henrik Wulf vom Altsch, von Altstrom Deutschland, der sagte, äh ja
Sie sind also jetzt für gestaffelte Angebote unterschiedlicher Qualitäten bei der Übertragung von Datenpaketen ohne dabei jemanden zu diskriminieren.
Das geht halt leider nicht, ne.
Ist es wirklich schwierig, ne? Also er sagte dann, was die, was die Telekom auch so vorantreiben möchte, ist so, wir haben dann in unterschiedliche Dienste, Klassen,
und innerhalb dieser Diensteklassen diskriminieren wir nicht mehr. Das wäre so was so das hat man in den USA ja also Jahrzehnte lang gemacht, ne? Oder jahrhunderte mit mit äh unterschiedlichen Menschenrassen, ja. Da gab's keine Diskriminierung. Da gab's einfach nur unterschiedliche,
Klassen von Menschen. Innerhalb derer waren alle gleich. Ja, also das ist die, nee, das, das, das Reden, sowas reden die seit Jahren.
Ja, ja, es ist, ja, es ist, es ist, es ist wirklich super, macht einem so ein bisschen fassungslos, ne.
Also da kann man nochmal den Artikel, habe ich da mal äh verlinkt. Auf Heise war der, äh den kann man sich da nochmal anschauen
und das Thema Netzneutralität wird, so hat es mir ein kleines Vöglein geflüstert bei den Datenspuren zweitausendzwölf, vermutlich äh irgendwie behandelt werden.
Welches ist eine Veranstaltung? Ist das CCC in Dresden?
Genau, die wir natürlich immer empfehlen, von der wir wahrscheinlich auch live berichten.
Genau. Ach ja,
In ihrer Community dürfen sie hinfahren, wo sie wollen. Das ist echt super. Na gut, das äh als Nachtrag zur äh Netzneutralität. Die äh Öffentlichkeit beschäftigt ja ganz andere äh Themen.
Ja, die Öffentlichkeit, dieses Thema kam eigentlich genau an dem Moment auf, wo es wäre die letzte Sendung aufgenommen haben. Bettina Wulf verklagt Google,
weil wenn man bei Google, wenn man auf die Google-Seite geht und langsam in das Fenster schreibt BET, dann sagt Google,
Tina Wolf Prostituierte. Als Empfehlung, was man denn eventuell wohl googeln möchte. Ähm man.
Nicht nur aber auch.
Genau, ist eine der einer der Vorschläge, den Google da bringt. Also Google sammelt offensichtlich häufige Suchanfragen und schlägt die dann den Nutzern als Service vor, damit die nicht so viel tippen müssen,
und ähm jetzt sagt Bettina Wulf, äh sie möchte bitte nicht, dass da Bettina Wulf Eskorth und Bettina Wulf Prostituierte äh vorgeschlagen wird von,
Und Google sagt, na ja, das ist aber unser Algorithmus und das äh der ist objektiv
und wir machen ja gar nichts. Wir es ist ja quasi es kommt nicht von uns, dass wir es dahin schreiben, sondern es sind unsere Nutzer und das ist eine objektives Erfassen des Interesses unserer Nutzer, was die wohl so googeln,
Ähm Google hat in der Angelegenheit schon fünf, sechs Prozesse gehabt, fünf Prozesse gehabt, wo irgendwelche Leute sich darüber beschwert haben und Google hat immer gewonnen. Das heißt, sie können ähm,
sie sie die Gerichte gehen mit der äh mit der Interpretation da Chor, dass Google da einen,
nicht, nicht Einfluss nimmt und ein Objektive Erfassung macht. Ähm,
Das heißt, irgendwann würde sich das auch wieder ändern, wenn die Leute das nicht mehr googeln würden. Ähm jetzt kann man aber, das ist eine sehr interessante ähm,
sehr interessante Beobachtung, wenn ich etwas googel, wenn ich da etwas reinschreibe und da kommt das Wort Penis drin vor oder Bad. Oder sowas? Oder Vagina, dann hört Google auf mit dem Vervollständigen.
So generell.
Generell, dann kommt gar nix mehr, zu Penissen schlicht, Google mir nichts vor.
Ach echt? Ausprobieren.
Ja, machen wir mal hier Live-Test. Google.
Linus Neumann Penis nichts.
Ja, Linus, Neumann, das steht überall und soweit du dann Penis so, dann so, sobald da steht, äh hat er keine, hat er keine Vorschläge mehr.
Lady Gaga Penis.
Oder wenn du jetzt so mal Penis, Penis.
Scheint auch schon zu helfen, aber vielleicht findet ihr auch.
Peni kommt nix mehr, ja? Also Google hat da in diesem Algorithmus, der ist wohl doch nicht ganz so ähm nicht ganz so objektiv, weil eine weitere Beobachtung ist,
man kann sich, glaube ich, sicher sein, dass wenn man den Namen einer Software googelt. Das, was am allerhäufigsten gegoogelt wird, wo der Name dieser Software drin vorkommt, wird der Name der Software Plus Touren oder sein.
Das ist einfach das, was du am meisten holst. Ja, ich meine, wenn du eine Software googelst, dann suchst du den Crack dazu.
Und ähm und auch das schlicht Google dir nicht vor. Wobei also wirklich hundertprozentig davon auszugehen ist, dass niemand Microsoft googelt oder so, weil er äh,
Also dat googeln halt Microsoft und nicht Microsoft World äh äh Produktbroschüre, ne?
Auch das äh äh unterbindet,
Kugel quasi. Äh und das sagen sie auch ganz ganz offen, dass sie eben die Urheberrechtsverletzung nicht befördern wollen.
Und jetzt ist es natürlich ein ein interessanter äh
Interessanter Punkt, also Kai Oberbeck von Google lässt sich zitieren mit die angezeigten Begriffe sind das algorithmisch erzeugte Resultat mehrerer objektiver Faktoren, inklusive der Popularität der eingegebenen Suchbegriffe.
Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, was ist denn Objektivität? Also die die also der der Algorithmus wird natürlich objektiv ausgeführt, aber die Kriterien, nach denen er ausgeführt wird, die müssen ja nicht unbedingt objektiv sein.
Und die Benenenkugel eben auch nicht. Und dann sind wir sofort eigentlich bei diesem Themenwelt der Meinungsfreiheit für Suchmaschinen,
Was wir vor einigen Wochen äh in einer Sendung schon mal angesprochen hatten. Und ähm das finde ich also insofern,
Relativ spannend.
Ja, also ähm.
Bin da auch sehr sehr gespannt, auf welcher Basis das überhaupt bewertet äh äh wird, weil ich meine, dass Google Einfluss nimmt auf die angezeigten Ergebnisse
Ist ja total klar, jetzt nicht nur wegen der von dir genannten Beispiele, sondern halt auch so diese Google Plus bevorzugen, die vor einiger Zeit da
äh Welle gemacht hat. Also das ist ja ähm das ist ja nicht so, dass das einfach alles nur so wäre. Und die Frage ist, was würde man Google alles vorwerfen, wenn sie nichts rausnehmen würden?
Ja, dann wäre die, dann wäre auch die Hölle los, ne,
also was was wir noch äh äh einfällt, sie diskriminieren noch den, das hatte Konrad Lischka auf Spiegel glaube ich geschrieben, sie diskriminieren den Rocco, ist ein ein italienischer Pornodarsteller, der wird ja auch nicht vor, der wird ja auch nicht empfohlen,
Also wenn du Rocco eingibst, dann, obwohl das äh so der Typ ist, der wahrscheinlich von allen Rockus am meisten im Internet ist,
aber äh äh auch den, auch den schlagen sie dir nicht vor. Und sie haben ja diese, sie haben ja regelmäßige Updates ihres Suchalgorithmusses gegen äh so SEO-Manipulationen,
Das heißt, da da gehen sie auch quasi gezielt greifen sie ein und ändern ihren Algorithmus. Also man kann da wirklich von Objektivität nicht wirklich,
sprechen, denke ich oder also wenn dann nur sehr, sehr eingeschränkt. Und wenn man nicht von Objektivität sprechen kann, dann ist man halt bei der Frage.
Die Frage ist, was ist was ist dieser Algorithmus? Also dass ein Algorithmus das anzeigt, ist mir schon klar, weil da wird ja jetzt nicht bei jeder Suchanfrage irgendwie eine Anfrage über Management gestellt,
sondern da gibt's halt den Algorithmus, nur dieser Algorithmus schließt halt auch Dinge aus
der Schließe ist halt aus nach Relevanz, er schließt es eben auch aus nach tja, potenziellen Seiteneffekten für Google Gesetzeslage äh Pipapo.
Genau, wie das juristisch zu bewerten ist, werden wir dann sehen, wenn wir sollte diese Angelegenheit tatsächlich ausgefochten werden. Der interessante Teil ist aber und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum Google
sich da unbedingt gegen wehren möchte, wenn die
Wenn die jetzt nur einmal so einen Prozess verlieren, ne, dann können die eine neue Abteilung aufmachen, hunderttausend Leute einstellen, weil alle Leute sich die ganze Zeit über Diskriminierung bei Google beschweren werden
vor du könntest dann irgendwann deine den Google Platz eins ginge nicht mehr darum, dass du eine vernünftige Seite hast und die vernünftig optimierst, sondern du könntest dir das irgendwie erklagen.
Also wie gesagt, dieses dieses diese Frage oder dieses Konzept der Meinungsfreiheit für Suchmaschinen ist irgendwie, also es kommt halt irgendwie so,
dem dem Konflikt an der Stelle echt ziemlich nah. Also so eine so eine Art andererseits, wenn man irgendwie so einen Kartell verhindern, Google ist aber im Prinzip schon so ein so ein Monopol Monopolist. Also es ist eine spannende Sache, wie man,
wie man das überhaupt also wie kennzeichnet man die die Verantwortlichkeit für diesen Algorithmus, der da stattfindet? Und was darf wie darf man den manipulieren und wie nicht? Ist echt spannend.
Ja, gut, können wir jetzt aber auch nicht weiter vertiefen, oder? Brauchen wir nicht. Nö, lassen wir jetzt erstmal so offen.
Noch ganz kurz, das war so schön. Äh bei Amazon, dieses dieses besagte Buch der Frau Wulf, ne, weil also das Ganze,
kannst du ja seit, seit einem Jahr oder einem halben Jahr oder was hast du das ja bei Google, warum hängt sie das jetzt irgendwie an die große Glocke und geht gegen Google und Günther ja auch vor, ja, weil sie gerade ihr Buch äh verkaufen will. Ähm,
Und dieses Buch, wenn man dabei Amazon ähm,
sich das anschaut, bei Amazon kann man Bücher taggen und es ist sehr schön, ähm mit welchen Text die ähm dieses Buch,
Natürlich äh verbunden wurde. Ja, also da war dann natürlich auch äh Prostituierte und so weiter, weil die hat Amazon aber jetzt entfernt. Aber so, ich sage nein zu diesem Buch, Ehrensucht, äh Ehrensold und Geltungssucht und so.
Schamlos, Unverschämtheit, maßlos schnorren.
Ja, das sind also sind ganz schöne Text. Also als nächstes wird sie dann wohl Amazon ähm äh anzeigen müssen oder verklagen müssen. Die einzigen, die ihr Buch da verkaufen, ja.
Ja, ich meine, es ist,
Natürlich sehr einfach. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich diese ganze äh Wulfgeschichte nicht so im Detail verfolgt habe in dieser Woche, auch weil ich sie gar nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen wollte
Also für mich ist das sowieso so ein Nichtthema irgendwie, was da jetzt ist mit ihr und äh,
Keine Ahnung, was da gelaufen ist. Ich nehme dir das irgendwie gerne ab, dass das äh äh ein reines Gerücht ist, wobei ich auch sagen muss, und wenn schon, ja, meine,
Ist ja jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, oder? Wenn man irgendwie Esquat gemacht hat.
Völlig uninteressant.
Ist auch irgendwie völlig in Ordnung, da äh,
mich mich stört schon so ein bisschen an dieser ganzen Debatte, dass das überhaupt so als so was äh anrüchiges gesehen wird. Okay, ich meine, wir wissen alle, wie das funktioniert in der Öffentlichkeit und vor allem in der Politiköffentlichkeit. Da ist das natürlich auf jeden Fall eine Keule. Insofern hat sie ja äh eine Menge,
Mut bewiesen, dass da sozusagen überhaupt so anzugehen und da einfach auch voll diesen Stralsundeffekt äh äh mit einzuberechnen, ja. Vielleicht hat sie sich auch nur gedacht,
gut ich kriege das eh nicht untern Teppich, äh äh zumindest nochmal eine Mark mitmachen.
Laut Wikipedia ist sie PR-Beraterin.
Ja, also so ein bisschen Einblick sollte sie da äh schon haben. Gewahrt ist sie sicherlich worden. Ich stecke da nicht drin, aber,
Gut, also das mich interessiert das nicht, groß dieser Google Aspekt ist natürlich jetzt interessant, was hat sie damit aufgerufen, da werden wir sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Ich glaube, da wird nicht sehr viel bei rauskommen, aber,
eine gute Antwort, was das richtige TM wäre, habe ich da auch ehrlich gesagt nicht parat.
Spannendes Thema deshalb.
Genau, deswegen gibt's das hier bei Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Genauso wie so ein super.
Leise.
Yeah.
Ja, ja, ja, oh Gott.
Feiglinge.
Oh Mann, ja, da kannst du mir mal kurz zusammenfassen, was der eigentlich tatsächlich äh geschrieben hat, weil das habe ich auch noch nicht äh verinnerlicht.
Rick Feiglinger hat äh.
Ist ja einer der Gründer, also der Gründer der ursprünglichen Pirat in äh,
der sich auch immer sehr freut, wenn die Deutschen hier irgendwie gewinnen und mitjubelt und auch lange Zeit da ausreichend äh hofiert wurde. Jetzt will ich wahrscheinlich keiner mehr kennen.
Jetzt will keiner mehr, jetzt ist er Schmuddelkinn, mit dem keiner mehr spielen will.
Relativ ausführlichen Artikel geschrieben, ich gebe den jetzt mal so wieder, wie ich ihn dort äh exzerpiert habe. Ähm und zwar sagt er, wir müssen den Besitz von äh Kinderpornografie,
legalisieren oder wie der legalisieren. Ähm Kinderpornografie benutzt er den Begriff. Wir wissen ja alle, dass der richtige Begriff.
Dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch sein sollte.
Es sei mir verziehen, wenn ich jetzt zwischendurch doch mal äh da den Fehler mache und.
Ich sage dann immer gern kipo. Ja, um einfach klar zu machen, dass es sich dabei im Wesentlichen um politischen Begriff handelt.
Ah ja, okay, ja. Äh genau das ist auch, glaube ich, sein Haupt äh äh Ding, weil es eben ein politischer Begriff ist. Und er sagt also, es gibt drei Argumente, warum wir äh,
den Besitz von Kinderpornografie legalisieren sollen,
Ähm das Verbot des Besitzes verhindert die Strafverfolgung, sagt er, weil alle, jeder, der es besitzt, im Prinzip Sorge haben muss,
Irgendwie äh rechtlichen Ärger zu bekommen. Dieses, das sehr plastische und jeden Tag vorkommende Beispiel, was er da nennt, ist,
Eine Person mit einer Google Glasbrille, also so eine Brille, die mitfilmt und äh sein Leben live streamt ins Internet. Äh macht einen Spaziergang im Park,
und entdeckt eine im Gebüsch stattfindende Kindesmisshandlung,
wird dadurch zum kriminellen, weil er äh verbreitet hat, ja und äh weil er aufgezeichnet, gespeichert und verbreitet hat und der Vergewaltiger lacht, weil der,
ähm dieser Google-Glasträger ihn jetzt nicht anzeigen kann. Ja.
Aus dem Leben gegriff.
Völlig aus dem Leben gegriffen, ne. Ähm also völlig, völlig, völlig äh lächerliches.
Aber er sagt quasi anderes Beispiel ist
das nehme ich jetzt mal ein mir bekannter Polizist sogar pikanterweise hatte bekam Spam in dem irgendwie ein nicht wirklich,
sage ich mal, als als illegal einzustufendes, aber trotzdem ein Bild eines jungen Mädchens war,
Und der war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch sehr unbedarft mit diesem Rechner, hatte gerade Internet bekommen, so vor ein paar Monaten und antwortete dann dem Spammer,
Und sagte, ey, äh lass mich in Ruhe, damit ich äh will damit nix zu tun haben, ja? Äh sonst zeige ich dich an oder so. Und dann schlug bei seinem Provider,
äh
Kontrollkeule an und entdeckte quasi diese da, dass er diese Datei, dieses Bild, was an dem an der E-Mail angehängt war, verbreitet hat, nämlich zurückgeschickt hat in dem Moment, als auf die E-Mail geantwortet hat.
Die Software sozusagen das einfach mit reingeworfen hat.
Mit reingeworfen hat. Das heißt, er schickte diese Datei zurück und dann ging er beim Provider ein rotes Lämpchen an, dem wurde sofort der Internetvertrag gekündigt.
Anstatt äh.
Er ist äh auf sein Leben,
so nicht so finde ich finde ich echt übel, ne? Also der sowas kann ja in dem Fall auch auch rufschädigend sein. Das heißt, bei dem ist ein rotes Lämmchen, der kriegt mit diesem Provider nie wieder äh irgendwo einen Vertrag. Ähm das heißt, äh,
Quasi dieses dieses ungewollte Zuspielen auf die Festplatte wäre natürlich auch so ein Fall. Also nur mal so als als kleines äh als kleines Beispiel. Ein ein weiteres Beispiel, was der Feigling nennt, ist ähm,
dass quasi der das Video, das verlinkt er wohl auch, hab's mir nicht angeguckt, dass einen den Mord an einem Teenager darstellt,
Wird eine Person umgebracht und dieses Video ist dort gezeichnet. Sagt, dieses Video wäre nicht illegal, weder der Besitz, noch das Verbreiten dieses Videos.
Da geschieht ein Mord drin. Ähm und er fragt dann eben, mit was mit welcher Maxime wir sagen, wir verbieten,
dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch, wenn wir dokumentierten Mord im Prinzip äh legalisieren. Ähm.
Der ist der Grund dafür, warum wir das wahrscheinlich tun oder der der naheliegendste Grund ist ähm,
Dass die Opfer dadurch traumatisiert werden, also ein Opfer, dem so etwas mal wieder gefahren ist, ähm,
Erfährt natürlich eine erneute Traumatisierung dadurch, dass diese oder kann eine erneute Traumatisierung dadurch erfahren, dass es mit der mit dem Wissen oder mit der äh ja mit dem Wissen oder tatsächlich,
Also mit dem Wissen leben muss, dass dieses Material irgendwie kursiert, dass Leute das haben wollen oder vielleicht dieses Material sogar einmal selber sehen muss.
Ist beim Mord auch genauso ein Thema, weil da gibt's ja.
Ja, da ist das Opfer halt äh.
Gibt's aber auch noch Eltern und Geschwister und also Freunde, also.
War mir jetzt auch nicht bekannt, dass ich dass ich ein Mordvideo verbreiten kann
ähm na ja also okay, das war also Argument Nummer eins und er sagt also es behindert die Strafverfolgung, weil wer ist, wer dieses Material hat, sich Sorgen machen muss, dass äh zur
Das irgendwie zu melden oder zur Anzeige zu bringen. Nehmen wir als Beispiel Jörg Haus, der in Deutschland ja ähm,
verurteilt wurde, weil er und das hat das Gericht ja sogar selber ihm damals im Urteil attestiert, dass er dieses Material,
augenscheinlich nicht zur Selbstbefriedigung gesammelt hat, sondern tatsächlich wohl Recherchen in diesem Milieu angestellt hat,
und dass aber das völlig egal ist, weil der Besitz strafbar ist und damit ist er jetzt ein Verurteilter.
Ein vorbestrafter, obwohl ihm attestiert wurde, dass er das nicht aus äh.
So ist nun mal der Paragraph.
So ist nun mal der Paragraph, ja? Ähm insofern kann man da sagen, dass äh dieses Argument, dass es die Strafverfolgung verhindert, greift so ein bisschen
dann sagt er das Verbot brandmarkt eine ganze Generation als Kindesmisshandler
Ähm und nennt dann so als das Beispiel von zwei Siebzehnjährigen, die sich die einvernehmlich Liebe machen und davon ein Video anfertigen. Und ähm das wäre also nach der aktuellen Rechtsprechung,
ähm Kinderpornografie, weil äh da Minderjährige drin vorkommen. Ich kann das jetzt nicht beurteilen. Er der stellt diese Behauptung so auf und der wohnt ja in Schw.
Bezieht sich aber im Wesentlichen alles auf Schweden, oder? Ja. Okay.
Ähm und dann ähm sagte er so diese der dahinter stünden irgendwelche äh,
äh fundamentalistischen Christen, die Kindern den Sex verbieten wollen,
Und deswegen hoffen, deswegen glücklich sind, dass es irgendwie so hohe dass jeder Sex von Jugendlichen irgendwie unter Kinderpornografie fallen würde und deswegen nicht verbreitet werden darf
also relativ coole Theorie auch. Ähm.
Ja und dann kommt er sozusagen überhaupt erst mal auf das, was er eigentlich sagen will. Das Verbot auch deshalb nicht passt, weil es ja irgendwie auch der Content Industrie in die Hände äh spielt.
Genau und da sagt er, der das das dritte Argument, der Kampf um die Meinungsfreiheit wird in der Schlacht um Kinderpornografie entschieden. Und da hat er wahrscheinlich Recht mit diesem Argument.
Oder mit dieser mit dieser Feststahlstellung und sagt vergleicht also diese Datei auf einer Festplatte und sagt,
mit einem Buch in einem Regal und wenn man jetzt den Leuten sagen würde, ähm du hast ein Buch im Regal und da kommt jemand in dein Haus,
nimmt das Buch daraus, verbrennt das Buch und verhaftet dich. Das ist im Prinzip das, was im Moment stattfindet mit äh dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch. Und ähm,
dass das eben der Grund ist, warum ja, da gibt's dieses dieses unglaublich oft äh äh hervorgeholte Zitat eines,
Lobbyisten der Content Industrie, der sagt, sie lieben äh dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch, weil das das äh weil das die ähm in der Bevölkerung die Möglichkeit ist, Verständnis für Zensurmaßnahmen und äh Traffic Überwachung
herzustellen. Das hatte er irgendwo hinter verschlossener Tür mal dummerweise zugegeben. Und ähm.
Das ist natürlich da, da hat er auf jeden Fall recht. Also er sagt, wenn wir sagen, Kinderpornografie ist keine legitime Ausdrucksform, dann sind wir nicht mehr weit davon entfernt, dass es auch kein, dass es auch
Dinge gibt, die dann vielleicht keine legitime Meinungen mehr darstellen. Und,
schließt so ungefähr mit der, mit der Meinung, dass oder mit der mit der Feststellung, dass dokumentierter Kindes äh Missbrauch ekelhaft ist und äh fürchterlich, aber durch seine Existenz nicht die Grundfeste der Gesellschaft
ähm,
erschüttern würde und oder bedroht, während es eine Zensurinfrastruktur und eine Überwachung der Gesellschaft sehr wohl tun würde. Und ähm.
Schließt dann also, dass wir,
dass wir die die Schlacht um die Meinungsfreiheit im Netz äh äh gewinnen müssen, indem das Verbot von ähm.
Kinderpornografie aufgehoben wird, damit Verbot des Besitzes von Kinderpornografie aufgehoben wird, damit äh dieser Hebel nicht mehr vorhanden ist.
Hm. An der Stelle erlaubt mir äh einen Querverweis ähm,
auf eine CAE äh Sendung, die ich gemacht habe im Mai zweitausendneun, also so in der Hitze der Zensursolar äh Geschichte, ja heißt auch so, Kampf gegen Zensos Solar, wo ich mich mit Scozy unterhalten habe
und das äh ist ein sehr interessantes Gespräch, wo wir also insbesondere eben auch wirklich dieses Kipo als politischer Hebel
von mehreren Stellen beleuchten, also wer da sozusagen mal Lust hat, sich da nochmal ein bisschen tiefer einzuhören, könnte das äh machen CRE hundertvierundzwanzig, ist das.
Super ist echt, also ist wirklich spannend, sich damit mal äh auseinanderzusetzen. Es ist im Prinzip wirklich so, dass du heute in,
Seit einigen Jahren sowieso nur noch Politik machen kannst, also wirklich Politik im Sinne von,
wirklich etwas ändern, indem du entweder ähm Kinderpornografie oder Terrorismus ins Feld führst. So, das sind die beiden Dinge, mit denen du äh seit einigen Jahren die Welt irgendwie äh in Atem halten kannst als als
politischer Gestalter. Alles an, bei allem anderen hast du eigentlich keinen wirklichen Hebel. Na ja, ähm Feiglinge schreibt das da, ähm,
Und es ist natürlich klar, dass das ein riesige Aufmerksamkeit äh nach sich zieht. Piratenpartei Deutschland distanziert sich sofort und macht aber schon in der Überschrift ihrer Pressemitteilung äh den Fehler davon zu sprechen, er wolle Kinderpornografie legalisieren,
Das ist halt nicht das, was er ähm was er möchte, sondern er will halt den den Besitz. So, das ist.
Und schon gar nicht die Erstellung, ja ja.
Das wäre also, man könnte sich das vorstellen, wie so etwas äh was wir in Deutschland auch bei Drogen haben, dass man äh so eine Art geringe Menge, ja, ähm ja, also finde ich, finde ich eine finde ich eine äh.
Ja, zumal das ja der Besitz im Wesentlichen halt auf, ja, weiß ich nicht genau, Pädophilie et cetera hinweist und,
unbedingt jetzt auch äh einen direkten Link, also kann natürlich sein, aber es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt in der Regel so, dass es direkt jetzt auf die Täter, äh die das eigentlich verbrochen haben.
Genau, es sind es sind nicht die Täter,
Und äh da da gibt's also auch noch einen sehr schönen Artikel von Udo Fetter zu, der äh tatsächlich in seiner Tätigkeit als Anwalt auch öfter mit solchen Dingen zu tun hat, der einfach nur mal so empirisch feststellt, es sind,
ähm nicht nur Pädophile
äh äh sage ich mal, Minderjährige belästigen, sondern ähm häufig auch Erwachsene, die einfach keinen anderen finden und die, die halt Kinder nehmen, weil die weil die schwach sind oder so,
Außerdem stellt er fest, dass es eigentlich kein lukrativen Markt für diese Materialien gibt, die eine äh der eine gewerbliche Produktion irgendwie,
ähm motivieren würde.
Außer meine glaubt natürlich Ursula von der Leyen, die von einem Millionenmark.
Zerfetzt, millionenmarkt, ja,
Und ähm dann erwähnt er auch die Möglichkeit der Eindämmung tatsächlich hervorfälle durch Pornographie, also quasi so als so Kinder äh Pornographie, als das Metadon für äh Pädophile, ja. Ähm,
Also man kann einige der Argumente oder einige der Beispiele, die der Feiglinge da anführt echt als ähm.
Als äh ziemlich beknackt äh markieren. Ähm ich kann auch sehr gut nachvollziehen, dass die Piratenpartei Deutschland sich gerade heute,
echt nicht erlauben kann, äh mit dem Ding, mit unterzugehen, weil den also die These hat halt für die These,
musst du halt unglaublich für Verständnis werben,
und die musst du wirklich sehr ausführlich erläutern warum du diese Position hast und da kann ich sehr gut verstehen, dass die Piratenpartei ihre Pressemitteilung nach
sofort danach schießt und sich da irgendwie versucht so weit wie möglich von dem Mann äh zu distanzieren
Allerdings ähm sollten wir uns ja nicht, sollten wir uns ja in der Politik weniger an der Symbolwirkung orientieren, als vielleicht daran, was äh Gesetze und die Entscheidungen, die wir treffen, für tatsächliche Wirkungen entfalten,
da ist ja,
Auch geht's ja nicht nur um Kinderpornografie, sondern auch zum Beispiel bei dem Leistungsschutzrecht, das ist so ein Fall, da geht's also um Symbolwirkungen bei bei den Gesetzgebungen und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der falsche Ratgeber. Ja, also eine wir sind da nach wie vor,
in einer Debattenkultur, die also ein Gespräch über über diese Kinder äh Kindesmissbrauch ist eigentlich äh ein informiertes Gespräch, ein ein Abwegen von von Argumenten ist eigentlich kaum möglich in dem Bereich.
Und Feiglinge hat jetzt auch mal gezeigt, äh was wie's Leuten ergeht, die da vielleicht mal äh eine etwas andere These ins Feld führen wollen.
Aber äh Udo Vetter plädiert ja dann auch sozusagen eher für eine Anpassung der äh Ausnahmen als jetzt äh eine generelle Legalisierung da ins Feld zu.
Also Udo Udo Fetter ähm argumentiert genauso wie so was wie so eine so ein kontrollierter Abgabe, könnte er sich vorstellen oder eben äh natürlich, dass äh dass man die Regelung anpasst, dass sowas wie es dem passiert ist
ähm oder wenn ich dann halt heute Abend noch meinen Spaziergang im Park mache mit meiner Google-Brille, ähm dass ich dann da nicht irgendwie im Knast landen kann, wenn ich da auf also.
Ob sich der Bundestag durchringen kann, nachträglich wieder ein zu rehabilitieren, glaube ich, ja nicht so richtig, aber äh wer weiß.
Ja, also die die Idee, das Thema mal so aufzugreifen, ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt und man kann das,
Kann da auf jeden Fall mal drüber sprechen. Es ist auf jeden Fall der
Befund steht auf jeden Fall, dass das im Moment und deswegen dagegen wehrt sich auch gerade dieser Morges EV äh entschieden, der die Missgrausopfer gegen Internetsperren, dass,
Im Prinzip mit dem Leid dieser Person, ohne überhaupt mit ihnen zu reden, seit vielen Jahren Politik gemacht wird,
Und zwar mit relativ unlauteren und relativ populistischen Methoden. Und das ist unabhängig davon, wie jetzt vielleicht eine zukünftige, wünschenswerte Gesetzeslage aussieht. Auf jeden Fall auch ein Missstand, den wir da beobachten.
Jod.
Cool, ich hab's geschafft, das Thema zu behandeln, ohne meine eigene Meinung dazu zu sagen. Bei den Shitstorm gebe ich mir nämlich nicht.
Gut, kommen wir äh auf andere Themen, wo man äh ein Fahrrad draufhauen kann.
Na, wir kommen, wir kommen, wir sind ja eigentlich sogar thematisch noch sehr nah dran. Ähm wir wir hatten die Internetsperren ähm in Deutschland, sollten ja genau zur äh,
zum äh Kindesmissbrauch äh greifen
und ähm wir bleiben bei bei der Netzkontrolle, denn die US-Provider haben schon zweitausendelf angekündigt,
sie auch ein Warnhinweismodell haben wollen. Und zwar im äh Bereich des Urheberrechts. Das äh wir haben das ja in mehreren Sendungen schon behandelt. Der Warnhinweis wird einem erteilt in,
Verstoß gegen das gegen das Urheberrecht kommt dann irgendwie eine Warnung, ja? Äh entweder direkt am Bildschirm oder Bildschirm oder mit einem Brief oder so,
So richtig sind sich die US-Leute da auch nicht ganz klar. Normalerweise heißt so ein Verfahren Freestrikes, weil in Frankreich die,
die Planung ist, dass man oder die, die aktuelle Gesetzeslage, glaube ich, immer noch ist, dass man mit dem dritten Strike dann eine Sanktion erfährt, äh welche im Zweifelsfall darin besteht, dass einem das Internet mal abgedreht wird,
oder dass es in seiner Geschwindigkeit gedrosselt wird. Ähm,
Also irgendeine irgendeine Sanktion soll einem irgendwie äh soll einem widerfahren, wenn man zu oft zeigt, dass man irgendwie äh mit das Internet nicht so nutzt, wie äh andere Personen das vorsehen, dass man es nutzt.
Und jetzt haben die USA äh im Rahmen der, wie heißt die Gruppe,
des Centers, das Center for Copyright Information, das hat sich also schon vor einiger Zeit mit den großen Providern, die haben sich irgendwie zusammengetan und haben gesagt, so, jetzt machen wir mal hier äh Warnhinweis-Modell. Und die haben jetzt angekündigt, sie wollen das also noch in diesem Jahr ähm.
Tatsächlich dann äh also an den an den Start bringen. Und bei sie wollen aber ein Sixtrikes Modell, keine Ahnung, warum sie jetzt von drei auf sechs gegangen sind und wenn ich den sechsten Strike erfahre,
Dann ähm muss ich mich dann ist die Sanktion, die ich erfahre, ein Lehrvideo. Ich muss ein zehnminütiges Lehrvideo schauen,
Äh welches mich über die möglichen Gefahren meines Tuns aufklärt.
Wo muss man sich das dann anschauen?
Verstehe das so, dass der Provider dann irgendwie sagt, so Internet.
Installieren dann eine Software auf meinem Computer und dann.
Internet geht erst wieder weiter, wenn ihr das hier gelesen hast oder wenn ihr drei Fragen zu dem Video beantwortet hast oder wie auch immer. Ich habe das ähm.
Oder so wie bei Clockwork Orange, dass man so einen Kinosessel einer träufelt ab die ganze Zeit Feuchtigkeit in die Augen und äh die weit aufgerissenen Augenlidern schaut man sich dann das alles an irgendwie zur Butze, Musik von Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart.
Ja, ja, ja, so was. Also.
Entschuldigung, Ludwigs von Beethoven. Ja, das stimmt, das war Beethoven, ne? Ludwig Fun. Du gute alte Ludwig Fun.
Ja, das stimmt, das war Beethoven, ja. Der gute, alte Ludwig fanden, ja. Und ähm also ein Lehrvideo, also ich.
Du kannst dir schon vorstellen, also die die möglichen Gefahren deines Tuns, das ist natürlich deine Viren äh befallen deinen Computer, wenn du äh Filme runterlädst oder so, ne. Und ähm.
Teil fünf. Na ja, es ist furchtbar.
Äh Problem ist net, also das Problem, warum das natürlich enorm relevant ist, ist, wenn das jetzt in USA wirklich eingeführt wird, dann haben wir ähm,
wirklich äh international die Kacke am Dampfen, ne? Man kann sich im Moment noch darauf beziehen, dass das in ähm,
Frankreich irgendwie äh zum absoluten Desaster geworden ist, das hat OP-Gesetz, was sie da haben,
aber die USA wären dann wirklich so natürlich der der,
Der Dammbruch mal wieder, ne. Ich würde den Darmbruch jetzt nicht hier äh strapazieren, aber ähm das wäre also sehr.
Ungünstig, wenn die, wenn die USA das tatsächlich machen.
Ja, diese Hadopi äh Geschichte hat mir, glaube ich, hier gar nicht äh äh behandelt. Da gab's doch neulich einen Bericht äh auf Netzpolitik org, äh dass da eine Auswertung stattgefunden hätte, dass es irgendwie Hadopi nur,
Drei Verurteilungen oder Anklagen überhaupt nur gegeben hätte oder und unter einer einstellige Zahl und unsinnige Kosten.
Ja ja das also ich habe die Zahlen jetzt auch nicht genau im Kopf, aber äh es stimmt, da war also dieses ganze Ding, ich meine Adopi läuft ja bringt ja sowieso irgendwie nichts, ne? Also es ist nach vierundzwanzig, nach zwei Jahren vierundzwanzig Millionen Euro haben sie da verbrannt.
Hinfälle, genau.
Vierzehn Fälle sind bei der Staatsanwaltschaft gelandet. Keiner wurde verurteilt. Ähm.
Hurra. Total sinnvoll.
Ja, auch da also es scheint es wieder so etwas äh wie ich gerade schon sagte, da wird eher Symbolpolitik gemacht als äh sich daran zu orientieren, was vielleicht wirklich eine die Folgen dieser äh Gesetzgebung sind, ja.
Sechzehn sechzig Beamte sind da irgendwie beschäftigt bei diesem H-Dopi drin, Ding. Und jetzt soll das Budget, soll denen das Budget gestrichen werden für den für den Killefit, den sie da machen?
Na gut.
Aber wenn wenn den mit der Budgetstreichung äh gedroht wird, kann das natürlich auch heißen, dass die jetzt irgendwie in den nächsten paar Wochen auf einmal hunderte von Fällen an die an die Sonne bringen, ne? Das äh gibt's ja immer zwei Möglichkeiten, auf eine Budget, kürz angekündigte Budgetkürzungen zu reagieren.
So
Kommen wir nach Großbritannien? Ja. Das Vereinigte Königreich.
Interessante, interessante Entwicklung in Großbritannien, da das wird gerade, sage ich mal, in der
Hackerszene kontrovers äh betrachtet. Und zwar der Staatstrojaner aus dem Hause Gamma International, den wir jetzt inzwischen schon weiß ich,
mehreren Sendungen behandelt haben.
Berichtete.
Blognetz wird natürlich berichtete mehrmals. Und ähm nachdem das jetzt irgendwie,
bekannt wurde, hat sich die Gruppe Privacy International ähm da mal mit diesem Thema auseinandergesetzt und die haben bereits im,
Juli zwanzig zwölf der Regierung Fragen gestellt. Eine Frist von ein paar Tagen gesetzt und gesagt, sonst dann werden wir rechtliche Schritte einleiten
und zum zur Verhinderung aktueller Einsätze von Finn, führen. Der Grund dafür ist, dass ähm es ja Beweise dafür gab, dass sie mit ihr, dass ihr Programm zumindest in Ägypten gepitcht haben
Also das, nachdem in Ägypten die Revolution stattgefunden hat, hat man dann da irgendwie so eine Art Angebot von Gamma an die ägyptische Regierung gefunden, äh wo sie eben Lizenzen für für ihre Software da äh an.
Ja, warum sollte nochmal erwähnen, auch wenn's vielleicht schon klar geworden ist, Gamma ist halt ein Unternehmen in in Großbritannien.
Ja, äh wobei, also eigentlich auch komisch, die gibt's auch in Deutschland, ne? Und der Besitzer ist auch ein Deutscher, ja, also es wird äh Gamma limited ist
limited ist das, glaube ich, ist also in in UK ansässig. Keiner, also es ist unklar, wieso das so ist oder jetzt weiß ich nicht wieso der äh Firmenbesitzer Martin Münch,
Ist ein Deutscher. Ähm.
Anmelden ist auch billiger als eine GmbH.
Limited ist billiger. Also welchen Grund auch immer er sich dafür ausgesucht hat, seinen Sitz in die UK darzulegen, wird ihn jetzt auf jeden Fall grade ärgern,
Äh weil weil's ihm da jetzt, wie gesagt, an den Kran geht. Und zwar uns nochmal kurz zusammenzufassen. Diese Software wurde also in Ägypten gefunden
in, in Oman und wurde eben auch in Bahrain eingesetzt, das war ja das wie sie letztendlich auch in Form von Code dann der Öffentlichkeit in die in die Hände fiel, es handelt sich um einen
Staatstrojaner Software, falls das bis jetzt noch nicht klar war. So und jetzt sagen die ähm sagt dies der Secret Terry of State, dass,
ein ist, also sind äh Dinge, die auch einen mit einer militärischen Verwendung zugeführt werden können,
und begründet wird diese Einschätzung damit, dass sich darin Kryptographie befindet. Und das mache ähm,
Zu einem militärisch nutzbaren Produkt.
Da sind wir ja schon wieder zurück in den Neunzigern.
Da sind wir zurück in den Neunzigern, in den Cryptowals, als es nämlich genau darum ging, dass äh starke Verschlüsselungs,
Algorithmen irgendwie einer Transportbeschränkung unterliegen sollten, weil sie als militärisch nutzbare ähm Güter klassifiziert wurden.
Erinnere mich da, das war, da war ich noch so jung, dass ich diesen äh komplexen Zusammenhang nicht so ganz verstanden habe. Ich weiß nur, dass ich Berlinux immer nur den
den hundertachtundzwanzig bittverschlüsselnden Netzcape runterladen konnte, aber nicht den zweihundertsechsundfünfzig.
Genau, es gab da so eine erste Frage, aber so ursprünglich war es halt so, dass so generell
Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen als Exportwaffe
gedeutet wurden, ja, also weil das ist ja irgendwie evil und so und das darf ja aus den USA nicht herausexportiert werden, das ist dann natürlich dann mit dem Aufkommen des Internets und von Datennetzen so absurd gewesen, ja, also bitz daran zu hindern, irgendwie das Land zu verlassen,
Und äh das Gipfelter übrigens in dieser netten äh Anekdote,
mir auch gleich wieder Gelegenheit gibt, noch einen weiteren CRE äh zu pluggen, ähm dass ihr dann diesen,
Algorithmus wie ausgedruckt haben, den South Code, also die Software durfte nicht exportiert werden, ne? Also nicht, dass wir die Daten, ne? Und dann ähm weil die Bücher aber sozusagen vollständig unter Freedom of Speech fallen,
Also unzweifelhaft,
ja? Äh unter man also die Bücher mit dem gedruckten South Code selbstverständlich ähm das Land verlassen lassen und dann
wurde das halt damals auf dem Hacker Camp Hip irgendwie in Holland äh alles wieder eingescannt,
Äh der Plug ist CRE hundertzweiundsiebzig, kann ich sowieso jedem empfehlen, der auch nur halbwegs an Hackergeschichte ein Interesse hat, ein Gespräch mit Rob,
ähm CRE hundertzweiundsiebzig Holland, Holland und die Hacker, genau.
Eine der coolsten CRE Folgen.
Großes Kino und äh ja, das kann man sich dann mal anhören, da äh ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass wir das dort äh etwas beleuchtet haben,
So oder so, äh das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich fragwürdig das Ganze auf
Kryptobasis zu machen, ist überhaupt äh fragwürdig, wie man denn das überhaupt ähm beurteilt. Meiner Meinung nach sollte das natürlich so eine politische äh äh Geschichte sein, dass man jetzt solche äh Spy-Software,
so im Kontext Waffe stellt. Vielleicht könnte man das einfach auch gesetzlich so konkret regeln, dass man wirklich von äh Software redet, die halt äh,
als Überwachungsmaßnahme greift bloß grad so ein Land wie Großbritannien, was einfach mal in einem Überwachungsexzessorgas.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund. Das ist wahrscheinlich.
Das das ist also wirklich äh absurd, ja, das das man glauben könnte, das könnte man auf der Basis politisch durchsetzen.
Also es scheint wirklich also genau das, was du sagst, könnte echt der Grund sein, dass sie quasi sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt über den über also der Überwachungsteil dieser Software ist ja der sehr viel naheliegendere, um das Ganze jetzt als einzustufen.
Kann man ja sofort sagen, hier Cyberwall oder so, ne, Cyberwarphe.
Ist es eigentlich auch. Also in dem Ausmaß, äh wie das Ding ein Computer äh äh unterwandert, ist das eine Cyber-Waffe in meinen Augen. Ähm,
seine eine enorme Spionage-Software, ja? Und ähm
aber wie du schon sagst, es scheint irgendwie relativ offensichtlich zu sein, warum die Briten sich den Teil irgendwie nicht geben wollen. Ähm weil sie, sonst müssten sie irgendwie ihr Land dicht machen, weil es alles ist. Dieses Gesichtserkennungs
Sie sieht die wie, was sie da irgendwie an jeder Wand hängen haben oder so. Ähm.
Und es gibt, wie gesagt, auch sehr viele, die das sehr kritisch sehen, dass ausgerechnet dieser Kryptoaspekt jetzt da herangezogen werden soll und dass uns das vielleicht in zwei Jahren nochmal an ganz anderer Stelle wieder ein Dorch im Rücken ist. Ähm.
Na ja klar, ich meine, stell dir vor, es wird irgendwie wieder so ein neuer Krypto Algorithmus äh erfunden, ja?
Irgendeiner neuen mathematischen Entdeckung im Bereich Primzahlen, der tut sich ja auch gerade irgendwie wieder mal was äh sozusagen einen neuen Riegel vorschiebt und es gibt mal was, was was nicht entschlüsselt werden kann oder wo man nicht weiß, wie einfach es oder schwierig es ist
das so äh entschlüsseln und dann wird dann halt schnell mal so eine Software verboten, das ist auch sehr schwierig, ne.
Also es gibt ja auch heute schon äh glaube ich ganz ganz brauchbare Verschlüsselungs äh Möglichkeiten, aber äh ja, also den die Kryptowurst wollen wir irgendwie nicht wieder haben und das deswegen ist auch gerade der
der Vorstoß von Privacy International wirklich relativ kontrovers diskutiert
Was ist aber, was, wenn man mal die positive Seite sehen würde, wenn die Briten das jetzt machen?
Dann muss Gamma sich eine Genehmigung holen, wenn sie den Schrott außerhalb der USA äh der EU verkaufen wollen. Das heißt, wir haben in Deutschland leider keinen Schutz davor,
Aber es würde also als,
Folge haben, dass sie äh ohne ohne Genehmigung nicht mehr in irgendwie nicht demokratische Länder exportieren können.
Zumindest nicht von den UK aus, ne. Ich meine, Sie können ja auch schnell dann noch die haben dann wahrscheinlich relativ schnell ihre Niederlassung in Malaysia oder.
Eh nie ganz verstanden, warum die nicht irgendwie äh.
Bisher ging's noch, ne?
Irgendwie.
Teuer.
Na ja, also in der Germany äh.
Behalten dir die Fahne hoch.
Privacy International sowieso eigentlich 'ne ganz also ist immer mein Blick wert die Seite was ich jetzt letztens empfunden gefunden habe die haben so 'ne Liste der
Statements von allen möglichen Firmen, die unter anderem auch Equipment bauen, mal dort gezeigt. Also es ist auf jeden Fall,
Pridas International da ist 'ne Gruppe die man mal so im die durchaus immer mal wieder interessante Sachen.
So sieht's aus. So, letzter Punkt.
Letzter Punkt, ja.
Tolle Leistungsschutzrecht der Rockrepierer des Jahres, wenn du mich fragst.
Ja, ähm also da gibt's gibt's jetzt eigentlich zwei kleine Neuigkeiten. Es gibt eine Petition,
Petition zur Ablehnung des Leistungsschutzrechts für Presseverlage, Online-Petition, ihr kennt das.
Irgendwie draufklicken, unterschreiben und dann gibt's eine Petition, wenn man fünfzigtausende erreicht in einer
bestimmten äh in einer, innerhalb einer bestimmten Frist muss eine Anhörung stattfinden vor dem Bundestag. Dort können dann die Petenten oder der Petent ihr Anliegen vortragen. Der Pete in diesem Fall ist die Piratenpartei Deutschland.
Ähm da gab's einige Kritik,
dass diese Petition aus einem auf quasi auch von einer Partei initiiert wurde wichtig war da glaube ich das Argument von Markus dass sagte
Das ist, wenn so einer Petition von vorne rein ein Parteienstempel äh aufgedrückt wird, man sich äh ein bisschen die ähm,
Die Unterstützung der anderen Parteien ausschließt, obwohl es nicht sein müsste. Ja, also äh sagte, als Beispiel, wie viele Piraten würden eine Petition,
zeichnen, wo die SPD ihren,
von vorneherein drauf hat, ja. Also da gab's den strategischen, kleinen äh Kritikpunkt und eine andere Beobachtung, die ich gemacht habe, war das am zwölften Oktober wohl ein Aktionstag stattfinden soll.
Ähm gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht. Und,
Das war mir gar nicht so bekannt und wer mir das mitgeteilt hat, war äh eine E-Mail von Google. Die international verschickt wurde,
in der es dann so hieß ja, sie wurde also auch an an.
Was heißt von Google, von welchem Teil, von Google?
Ja, warte, ich sage dir, ich öffne gerade das E-Mail-Programm und sage dir, wer sie verschickt hat. Und zwar war das der Derek, Derick. Derick. Derick Slater.
Ich dachte, der macht schon lange nicht mehr. Ach so. Derrick.
Derek Slater und der ist ähm.
Policy Manager bei Google, ja? Und er schrieb also auch an an Gruppen ähm.
Englischsprachige, europäische Gruppen und so und sagte, ey, schau mal, ähm.
Ich wollte euch nur mal darauf aufmerksam machen, dass es hier im Oktober. Also der macht quasi,
weist ähm.
Weißt du schon mal daraufhin.
Weist Organisationen, in dem Fall außerhalb Deutschlands in Europa daraufhin, dass es da einen Aktionstag geben wird. Und er weiß von diesem Aktionstag, bevor die Gruppen,
Die deutschen netzpolitischen Gruppierungen überhaupt davon wissen,
Was dann dazu führt, dass Deutsche netzpolitische Gruppierungen dann E-Mails erhalten von ihren europäischen Freunden, die sagen, ey, ich sehe, dass ihr da das unterstützt und ähm,
Falls ihr da Unterstützung braucht, warum meldet sich der Google Furz hier bei uns und nicht ihr?
Ja, Google weiß halt alles und wir wissen nur manches, ne? So ist das halt.
Google weiß es, weiß es offensichtlich schon vorher, ja? Und Google wirbt also aus offizieller Position im europäischen Ausland zumindest, also zumindest im europäischen Ausland äh für die Bewegung gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ja, also dass die Piratenpartei dahinter steht, ist sicherlich problematisch, zumal man davon ausgehen darf, dass äh äh sie dann am Schluss, wenn dann diese Petition irgendeine
Wasserstandsmarke überschreitet dann auch entsprechend pathetisch daher jubeln wird
Also ich muss sagen, die der Pressemitteilungsoutlet Teil äh äh der Piratenpartei und auch dieser Twitter-Account im Übrigen, ja, das ist also wirklich das,
Merkwürdigste an diesem ganzen Unternehmen überhaupt. Es ist ein Twitter-Account, der ist sowieso.
Ich glaube.
Zumindest regelmäßig vor die Nase. Ich weiß grad nicht, ob er mir einfach nur in die Timeline retweetet wird oder äh kann schon sein, dass ich mir das irgendwie mal ähm anschaue. Ich meine, muss ich das ja mal,
Man muss sich das ja mal geben, aber äh ja, das ist äh hektisch, ne? Na gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. So, sind wir durch?
Ja, ich wollte noch ganz kurz einen einen Hinweis äh geben an dieser Stelle,
Also was was wir da beobachten, dass also Google jetzt hier für die Bewegung gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht äh ein bisschen
die Trommel rührt ist das nennt man eben Astro Turfing ne? Also 'ne Firma verlagert ihren Lobbyismus in den in den Aktivismus.
Kann man jetzt, kann man so stehen, wie man möchte. Sicherlich ist der Kampf gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht in unser aller Interesse und aber natürlich auch insbesondere im Interesse von.
Ja gut, ich meine, dann würde es ja bedeuten, dass das sozusagen äh von Google initiiert ist. Würdest du das äh jetzt unterstellen wollen.
Ich sage nicht, dass es von Google initiiert ist, ich sage nur, dass Google selbstverständlich diesen Kampf äh unterstützt mit Mitteln, die Google hat. Und die Mittel, die Google hat, sind natürlich auch Geld.
Ja gut, aber.
Ist auch gar kein Problem. Also es ist überhaupt gar keine.
Ja gut, aber Astro Turfing bezeichnet ja, wenn sozusagen die Leute, die tatsächlich dort diejenigen sind, die diese Klage anführen, bezahlt sind und nur so tun, als wären sie Aktivisten. Das würde ich hier nicht unterstellen wollen oder.
Würde ich aber Astro Turfing nicht fassen, den Begriff. Ich bin aber noch gar nicht fertig. Ich will.
Ja
Google, Google sorgt sich also darum, dass dieser Protest auch schön funktionieren kann, ist bereit, ihn zu unterstützen und das ist ja auch völlig, völlig verständlich, dass sie das tun.
Ja, soll sie mal hier mit ihren mit ihren Gigabit äh äh Hausanschlüssen mal kommen? Ja.
Und.
Das nehme ich jetzt zum Anlass, darauf hinzuweisen, dass ähm wir hier und da gibt's eine sehr schöne Rede von Wolfgang Blau, die er auf einem äh Urheberrechts ähm,
auf einer Urwahlrechtstagung der Grünen gehalten hat, die verlinke ich auch in den Kommentaren, die habe ich beim letzten Mal vergessen zu erwähnen, ähm wo er also sagt, was,
Was beobachten wir im, im Fall dieses Leistungsschutzrechts? Die Presseverlage haben inzwischen sogar selber, lasst euch das kurz erklären.
Wolfgang Blau muss man glaube ich.
Chefredakteur von Zeit Online.
Ist der Chefredakteur von Zeit Online, der Wolfgang Blau. Er hat eine sehr, sehr ähm sehr wohlüberleichte und sehr gute Rede gehalten zu diesem Thema des Leistungsschutzrechts. Und er erwähnt darin, dass die Presseverlage sicherlich auch inzwischen verstanden haben,
dass ihnen dieses Leistungsschutzrecht äh keine Vorteile bieten wird. Und dass sie es trotzdem natürlich,
Man nennt dieses Phänomen auch äh too much investit to quit. Also ich habe mich zu zu viel dafür da dafür reingehängt, als dass ich jetzt noch aufgeben könnte. Ich muss das jetzt durchkämpfen. Das das man mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht inzwischen bei so einer so einer Art Prinzipienfrage ist,
Es muss jetzt einfach durchgezogen werden. Die die Verlage müssen auch diese Macht einfach mal zeigen, dieses Zeichen einfach setzen.
Wir setzen sogar Gesetze durch, die uns schaden.
Zum Bleistift, ja. Und wir wir haben also da jetzt diese.
Aha. Klingt super. Diese Verlage sind so die die neuen Ritzer der Gesellschaft sozusagen, ja? Also die sitzen da und schnippeln sich jetzt hier irgendwie ihre Pulsader rum oder so. Hier guck mal.
Ähm na ja, er äh schildert das nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher, da aber natürlich so dieser Vergleich ist äh durchaus gegeben. Und Google
Also was wir beobachten, quasi Verlage, die jetzt irgendwie aus allen Rohren mit ihrer mit ihrer mit ihren Publikationen versuchen, zu feuern, ja
und äh in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang ist ja auch so dieser ganze andere Copyright, äh was wir vor ein paar Monaten da hatten, ein Handelsblatt und wo wir überall die Titelseiten,
ja. Urheberrecht, Urbericht, Urheberrecht, Urberecht. Und jetzt haben wir auf der anderen Seite Google,
Die einfach sagen, ach weißt du was, komm, wir drücken einfach mal hier, wir unterstützen mal so eine Initiative äh gegen dieses Leistungsschutzrecht da
sehen wir einfach mal zu, dass die jetzt nicht daran scheitern müssen, Druckkosten für ihre Flyer äh nicht bereit liegen zu haben. Da sorgen wir einfach mal für, dann schreiben wir mal noch ein paar E-Mails und sehen zu, dass sich dieser Protest aus der Bevölkerung auch so ein bisschen kanalisieren kann
da da schauen wir einfach mal mit unseren Möglichkeiten mit rein. Um das jetzt mal positiv äh darzustellen. Man kann das auch sehr viel negativer darstellen, aber ähm,
Das ist auf jeden Fall mal doch ein interessantes so eine allgemein interessante Beobachtung. Und das wird jetzt ein Showdown,
Also ich finde, es ist jetzt wirklich der Showdown. Google irgendwie mit so, ey, wir sind das Volk, wir sind das Volk, ja? Und äh und die Verlage da oben irgendwie so, wie wir sind die Wächter der Demokratie und äh wir werden von Urheberrecht alles aufgefressen. Das ist jetzt wirklich,
Der ausgetragene Kampf zwischen irgendwie äh den Google-Leuten und den und den Axel-Springer-Leuten.
Ich komme echt so langsam vor, wie so ein SM-Club irgendwie, wo jetzt so der Google irgendwie die Peitsche äh äh hat, ja und die Verlage sich gerne auspeitschen lassen wollen. Ist völlig absurd, oder?
Ich kann da, ich kann da wenig, ich will da ja ich versuche das ja eher so als als Phänomen zu zu betrachten, also dieses Leistungsschutzrecht ähm.
Ich meine, irgendwann, irgendwann muss doch da auch mal die Vernunft einsetzen.
Nein, es geht in diesem Land nicht oder es geht sowieso nicht um Vernunft in Politik. Es geht nicht um Vernunft. Das ist eine der großen Trugschlüsse, dass man meint, diese diese es wäre irgendwie hier äh Ziel der Politik, großartig Vernunft zu haben.
Nicht immer, aber ausnahmsweise mal so.
Parlamentarische Demokratie, die wir müssen da irgendwie, du brauchst irgendwie ein Thema, was die Leute beschäftigt. Nun, es geht doch nicht mehr um das geht doch nicht um um Vernunft,
Also es wäre schön, ich wünsche es mir ja selber, aber die die Erkenntnis muss sich leider auch irgendwann ähm erlangen und und in vielen Jahren der Frustration äh versuchen, zu verdauen, dass äh
Politik nicht, nicht dem Anspruch genügt und auch nicht genügen will, dass es da um Vernunft ginge.
Okay. Kommen wir zum Ende hier. Linus.
Los. Die Welt ist so absurd.
Welt ist so absurd und durcheinander. Und äh ja, aber es macht durchaus Spaß, ihr dabei zuzuschauen einmal die Woche.
Alles von Vernunft geleitet, was für eine Blödsinn nicht langweilige Sendung, wenn wir hier machen.
Das ist ja Triebgesteuert, ne? Also wir können ja nicht anders.
Sind wir durch, wa? Oder? Gibt's noch welche Ausblicke?
Nö. Nee, Feierabend.
Termine nichts.
Nette Termine habe ich also die Termine, die jetzt irgendwie morgen stattfinden, habe ich ja schon letzte Woche angekündigt und mehr fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein.
Dann sind wir durch. Wir sagen tschüss. Bis bald.